you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is Game one
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between defending champion Vishy
Anand and challenger magnus carlsen time
controls for each of these 12 games are
40 moves in two hours and should you
meet that time control you gain an
additional hour for the next 20 moves
and should you meet that time control
you gain an additional 15 minutes with a
30 second increment for each move
thereafter so in this again first game
of 12 Carlsen had the white pieces and
opened with Knight f3
Anand replied d5 and for the most part
in the early going neither side is
confrontational going about development
without much tension developing their
minor pieces getting castled and it is
only at this point right here with the
move c4 do we finally have some tension
in the position where there is an
instance where there can be some capture
with D take C or C takes D so from here
getting the Queen Knight developed
similarly for white and now we have D
take C if the move Knight e4 is played
this is a common idea to exchange off
the King Knight for whites Queen Knight
and establish a position in short where
this bishop is opposite the one on g2
this is a position I feel that is
completely equal for black where you
establish this bishop on e4 and if this
knight on f3 is that removing black is
perfectly welcome to having the light
squared bishop s' off the board judging
on the current situation in the center
this bishop being the bishop on e4 being
considered black's quote unquote bad
bishop
but we did not have that it was not a
Knight to e4 but rather D take C much
more critical line as it stands right
now if we look at the structure its
symmetrical perfectly symmetrical on the
Kings side and with regard to the Queen
side not too much varies but now things
do change D take C B take C and now this
is well what has black just done black
has given up their foothold in the
center their central d5 pawn white now
has we could say a majority in the
center two to one majority in the center
but where is white maybe a little bit
weak or a little bit soft in their
position well it's the c-4 pawn which is
attacked right away with Knight to b6
and there aren't too many good replies
here for example 95 is immediately
challenged with Knight on f2 d7 and what
are you doing you're challenging the one
piece that's in your position you're
also trying to undermine a defender of
your c4 point using the tactic of
deflection so we wouldn't have that
white doesn't go into a position where
they're tethered to the defense of the
c4 pawn and instead pushes the knight
around with c5 the alternative of Queen
to b3 which seems quite natural to
develop a piece and defend well now
there's maybe some issue with more
pressure being placed on the pond and on
top of that it's now in a pin so what
may very well be best by white at this
point would be d5 CD CD and at the end
of it black turns out to be up upon what
may be best is Knight g5 trying to get
the bishop but after Knight f4 Knight
takes Bishop Knight takes Knight while
white is up upon this is not going to go
anywhere fast this is oh I should say
while white has the bishop pair and
black is up the pun there's no this
isn't any real compensation for giving
up that material
I believe black will be quite alright
with having
rook on c8 soon and the knight on c5 not
only hitting the queen but ender is
hitting that b7 point in other words we
would not have something like Knight
takes our Bishop takes b7 because of
Knight to c5 with the fork so this is
not a road we would go down you really
could stop your calculations at I guess
this point right here where if you're
having to play d5 there's going to be
that's an issue where you're having to
go down a line where you're giving up
upon this early on it's just not
happening it's not worthwhile so after
Knight b6 it was c5 and now this Knight
is a bit annoying to the bishop white
now drops back not the greatest move to
have to play but white wanted to
preserve that bishop I guess an
alternative would be to develop the
Queen that could get a little bit murky
with something like this this pond again
is a would be immune from capture this
Bishop would be one in short order we
did not have that the bishop does come
back to its home square and now we have
something very direct Knight to d5
putting pressure on this tactically
vulnerable c3 Knight it's unprotected
Knight d5 hits it and this is where we
had a great think by Carlsen we take
note on the right hand side with the
times it's 90 it's approximately 90
minutes that he has remaining and he now
decides on Queen to b3 after about 22
minutes
what other moves might there be if
Knight takes Knight I think black is
quite alright here converting that C
pawn into a central pawn and now the
knight on c4 all of a sudden has support
and black has a nice grip over this
efore square so not the road that
Carlsen really wanted to go down and
maybe the reason he spent so much time
on this move is because after Queen to
b3 he knew that Knight to a5 would turn
out to potentially lead to a quick draw
or in other words a threefold repetition
of position
the queen is with this last move is very
limited and if Knight to a5 is played
and it was the move played in the game
you'll note the Queen doesn't have very
many options she now has to react and
still defend the knight on c3 so what
was played is Knight to a3 and then the
knight drops back to c4 but before I get
into those final moves I do want to
point out an error that I made while I
was a live streaming I'm sure it was not
the only one but as I was live streaming
at twitch.tv slash chest network I noted
that if Knight took on c3 and replied to
this Queen b3 move I pointed out that
white has their pick of taking c4 or c3
but this is not the case
Queen to c4 would not be a good move
because if Bishop takes d4 I forgot this
tactical shot that black has available
where if now Knight takes bishop there
is now Queen takes Knight and if Queen
takes Queen this white queen is one back
in short order and at the end of it
black is up how many puns black is up to
pawns so that would not be a good thing
to be missing that I missed it on the
live stream but I caught my mistake
before I did this video of course so we
didn't go that down that route anyhow
but if Knight c3 in short yeah it's best
not to take this Knight on c4 but rather
take the one on c3 anyhow just admitting
my mistake what was played however was
going b3 night a five queen a three
night c4 Queen b3 and what do you know
who would have thought that Game one of
the 2013 World Chess Championship would
be a draw after just 16 moves that's how
it ended up and so where they have a
half a point each this is a long
ouch I'm looking forward to it I will
continue to do games there are videos of
each of these ensuing games and feel
free to stay connected and stay up to
speed as to who is going to turn out to
being the world champion
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you
[Music]